build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people this is
bidipi building Canadian artist
agonistic dick collaborates with bees to
alter man-made objects honeybee
alterations takes things like porcelain
figurines in conjunction with the bees
natural beeswax making process to create
altered sculptures and she uses the
artwork to help illustrate the delicate
relationship between humans and bees
daniel rossen makes interactive mirrors
out of things like trash fans weaved
materials and wooden pegs the sculptures
react in real-time to the movements in
front of them using custom software and
video sensors his installations have the
ability to respond to the specific
presence of the viewer making them part
of the piece itself
Michelle Jewell creates one-of-a-kind
stuffed animals body parts are made of
fleece material with unique clothing
sewn from up cycled and vintage fabric
all of the toys are hand sewn and
stuffed including plush fox friend horse
friend raccoon friend and even vermin
friend Jeff Highsmith built his son this
vision control deck featured on the make
youtube channel it has a map and a
magnetic backing to track the spaceships
route a huge control panel of LED
lighted switches and it recreates
real-life situations from actual NASA
missions such as when the crew of the
Apollo 12 mission was instructed to
switch SCE to aux after a lightning
strike draw stones and bones is a series
by French artist dzo Oliver that uses
bone and rock as a canvas when he was
out of paper for a short time he decided
to use a different natural material and
says that the rough smooth and absorbent
surfaces make for quite the adventure
also his paper illustrations are
incredible photographer vessel I Tamaki
uses force perspective baking soda and
Lego to create scenes from Star Wars
the lighting perspective and Composition
make the photos incredibly realistic and
never-before-seen scenes from
movie like last ship to rendezvous point
the backyard Falcon snowtroopers delight
and casual parking and now for the work
of Bruce Yan depicting iconic brands
with a pop-culture twist Jo mangram
creates beautiful artwork using sand he
has created over 650 public sand
paintings worldwide since 2009 Matt
grupe says the world is divided in so
many ways so it uses his artwork as
spontaneous creations in the streets to
act as vibrant catalysts for social
interaction playing using only empty
bottles Danish Group the bottle boys
play a mash-up of classic hip-hop songs
here's big beats performing a J Dilla
live mixtape for his unraveled project
Square pusher uses robots playing music
to create Z machines with a 78 finger
guitar and 22 drums
finally here's the official video for be
around by the peach Kings created by
Paul trilling
so make door b dps is a personal message
here on youtube or share them with
everyone over at facebook.com/vsaucetwo
w up
click here list to a brand new
installment of bidipi radio music
created and submitted by you guys also
check out your bidipi entire video
dedicated to the creations of vsauce
fans and as always thanks for watching